what's up reject nation I'm Greg out
button I'm John Humphrey we're gonna
watch Black Panther born for a greatness
MCU character tribute video this comes
from Chris medley my good buddy of a
Petry on top rewards your video request
this is from his channel he's been doing
these a little more frequently now we
saw one of history Captain America which
was great surprise they will put these
up and not get Block considered he's
using real artist Papa Roach born for
greatness is the song here in this video
ain't monetize we're watching it anyway
for you buddy let's check it out yeah
think I've only heard last resort
oh man there's a whole world waiting
here hey Steve
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm used to hearing them in this context
[Music]
running
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
vomiting
[Music]
my Panthers stairs one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's consumed you still me man kazumi
interesting any note hmm interesting
little coda that's actually part of the
song so I when I got from this was
imagine dragons as taking the Booker to
you out of that Papa Roach or depending
on which album this is for maybe Papa
Roach took a few cues from imagine
dragons I'm not sure but I have never
heard Papa Roach with like trap high
hats and pop production and you know hmm
yeah I mean they've always had the
rapping in there it was interesting you
ended on him on his his losing fight
when he gets thrown over the the
waterfall from kill bunker right he lost
his the final moment from the song other
than when you cut to where he's in the
plane at the beginning of Black Panther
but still that was really well edited
man you know I'd added a lot of the
action moments a lot of the Falls the
hits to the beats I'm always on the
lookout for them when I watch any
tribute video are they really editing
their cuts or specific actions to the
music and you definitely nail that this
seems like an odd song to use for a
black panther like when I would hear
this song like the Black Panther imagery
wouldn't come to mind so first was a
little weird but as it progressed I got
a lot better
well yeah and especially cuz you honed
in a lot on the action and a lot of the
physicality and stuff like that because
there is so much of that and a song that
goes kind of well in that sleek
futuristic but also hard-hitting impact
man a vibe you know he always pays us
into the lyrics I noticed like he's
always trying to match whatever they're
talking about the actual song there's
like a physical thing like running or
falling oh yeah when he says running
stop running like literally he uses the
clip from civil war but he's talking
about running and it stop writing is
when he's not running yeah so literal
creator but there's also like nope only
literal
trying to find the most literal
interpretations and I didn't realize how
much of a body language performance two
challahs character really is the whole
time oh yeah there's so much Terry yes
yeah yeah he gets roughed up he stares
he has to kind of process a lot of hard
information and then think of what's
best for way too many people you know
it's living a lot yeah
where does I feel like you know kill
monger gets a lot of the big dialog you
know I gotta say man like this video
looks like it's doing really well you
have two thousand eight hundred twenty
views I know you don't purchase views so
that's great and you're partnered with
Papa Roach on the ad revenue and you got
a pretty good amount of comments I know
that when you did the Captain America
one week guy two people to your channel
that one got more views but we're
looking at the view count before we've
uploaded our reaction to this so this is
great I'm really happy for you man well
like I know he works really hard on his
channel he's been going through some
tough stuff lately I mean how can it be
so rough when he's a photographer to go
check out his Instagram may you
photography or his photographic hawkgirl
all the time this guy acts like life is
rough that's the secret to happiness
photographing hot chicks you've got
nothing to worry about what are you some
more on your photography I mean I know
you've told me some of the real life
issues that you've been having real life
is over a real life is over hot chicks
that's where it's at he says he doesn't
flirt or sleep with any of them and I
say mistake what are you trying to be a
professional or something she said call
man you got to break those boundaries
now is the time now is the time yeah
well there's still no rules and it's the
Wild West we mean all of these things
but dude like this song you are born for
greatness and so was to Charlie you know
we need we need a spider-man one I went
what I liked about the ambitious task of
this is it seems like you probably
here's a song and it makes him flash of
these images I want to see another one
where you hear what the song is and you
go there's no way that could work mm-hmm
they makes it work
[Music]
it'd be cool if you did one for
spider-man from the MCU okay so the bad
touch and then spider-man yes operation
video hone in the high school elevator
you know and the light-hearted humor of
everything weird sexual tension where
you can do is go watch spider-man far
from home bring a camera record the
screen yeah that way you could rip
images in moments from there and put it
in there and then hopefully by using a
popular artists song in this case
Bloodhound Gang yeah a very popular with
you know illegal footage hopefully you
don't get your channel taken down you
don't get strikes they go this video is
so experimental it just seems like it
wouldn't work that both Bloodhound Gang
and sonia marvel hookin ago we love it
we're gonna use it on our social media
now to promote ticket sales for its it's
a perfect plan because even if the movie
studios aren't excited about it you know
Bloodhound Gang they're gonna want to
make this money with you and you can
argue fair use because you've changed
the visual with how crappy your cell
phone footage is gonna be and you're not
gonna use the sounds so technically
that's not even piracy get on it man
look we've been doing this YouTube thing
and doing reactions for several years
now we know exactly what makes
everything okay we know the rules of
YouTube so father's a follower a
guideline Oh
serious now he has a he has a playlist
called nostalgia which is so different
from this stuff I guess it kind of works
all fandom related in some way where he
basically goes over a video game that
you know is near and dear that was
heartening it as a breakdown review and
now a cease deconstruction of it that
are usually stuff that's been like
re-released yeah and it's great and The
Fantasticks like this guys netted or if
it's a lot of editing and so all his
work and he scripts those out and
they're wonderfully scripted so go check
out his channel today subscribe yeah
yeah you know the [ __ ] people say at the
end of their YouTube videos like that
like button
[Music]